[Music]
this week we
naturally provide you with another
original episode
this time it's about one of the most
popular animation franchises of recent
years
namely how to train your dragon after
three
hugely successful movies the last of
which was released in 2019
there is unfortunately no fourth part in
sight today
we talk about how likely it seems that a
fourth part will be released after all
and what it could be
about so have fun with our newest video
first we'll recap the storyline from
parts one two three to bring you up to
date
in the first part from 2010 we dive into
the world of the viking offspring hiccup
in contrast to his comrades hiccup is
very dainty and has little in common
with a fearsome
viking just like his father the
chieftain stoick hiccup has the desire
to kill a dragon
as the viking village is suddenly
attacked by dragons young hiccup is
given the chance to prove to his father
and everyone else
exactly what he's capable of at first he
succeeds in shooting down
a night fury a particular dangerous
species against the old viking tradition
however the two become
friends and hiccup's life is turned
completely upside down
finally the fight between dragons and
villagers is proclaimed to be over
and both sides live peacefully with each
other from then on
in part 2 from 2014 hiccup and toothless
as he names his dragon have been friends
for 5 years
during one of the many exploratory
adventures they come across a mystical
ice cave
populated by many dragons and especially
the legendary dragon rider
it eventually turns out that the masked
rider is hiccup's mother who was
believed dead
and that she lives among the dragons
here exploring the actually peaceful
beasts
the unscrupulous drago bloodthis who
fears nothing sees things differently
and wants to train the dragons for his
army in the end the conflict ends mildly
for the villagers as dragon loses
control of his army and has to flee
hiccup is appointed chieftain due to his
outstanding achievements and the village
is rebuilt part 3 was released in 2019
and continues the story of the previous
ones
hiccup and his girlfriend astrid take
care of the day-to-day business in burke
while toothless has risen to become the
leader of the dragon colony
the piece does not last for long of
course since a new threat looms
on the one hand a light fury enters the
life of toothless on the other hand the
evil dragon hunter grimmle is after the
dragon leader
the solution to the problem is to
discover the so-called secret world
where the dragons can live in peace
after a difficult confrontation with
dremel and the discovery of the secret
world
the alpha dragon toothless finally
manages to lead his fellow dragons to
the secret world
hiccup and astrid's personal happiness
also flourishes more than
ever as the two married the following
winter after settling down on the new
island
the film series ends with hiccup and his
family flying away on toothless in
stormfly
and his voice off screen saying that he
wants to keep the dragon's existence a
secret
until humanity is mature enough for them
to coexist peacefully
in addition to the three main films
there's also this small but
nice christmas special called how to
train your dragon homecoming from
the story revolves around the now
significantly aged spouses astrid
and hiccup and their two children zephyr
and nothing they're all preparing for
snuggle talk which is a big family
celebration with plenty of presents
hidden in the vikings helmets
over the course of the 22-minute
spin-off father hiccup tells his
children how important peace with the
dragons is
and as if by magic hiccup's old
companion toothless appears to share one
last great adventure
and to reminisce with his former master
before we discuss a potential plot for a
fourth part it should be said that
director dean de blah has already
clarified several times that no
fourth part is planned and that the
third part has already completed the
storyline
many fans were hoping that the
relatively large time jump at the end of
how the training dragon 3 would make
room for more content
and this is where the older hiccup and
the older toothless are united with the
families
the 22 minute christmas special on how
to train your dragon homecoming also
makes you long for more as even the
story of part 3 somewhat continued there
in our opinion there are 4 possibilities
for a continuation of the how to train
your dragon series
on the one side there could of course be
a direct sequel to part 3 in terms of
content
for example the plot could be said after
this special homecoming
and tell a final story of hiccup and
toothless do
would likely have another exciting
adventure but ultimately such a sequel
would probably feel
very repetitive and unnecessary the
ending of part 3 fits wonderfully with
the conclusion to the film series
and is a successful ending for both the
fans and the studio
thus a seamless sequel is the most
unrealistic scenario in our opinion
the second possibility would be a story
of hiccup's children nothing and zephyr
they could have reached teenage or
adulthood after a time jump and follow
in their father's footsteps
for instance two parallel stories of the
siblings existence could be told and the
story could eventually be brought
together
besides the aged characters from the
previous three parts new characters
could be introduced without losing the
charm of the original
the main problem at this point is that
hiccup simply cannot be left
out of the main role and that overall we
know far too little about the children
in addition the time jump that would be
necessary from part 3 to part 4
would probably feel kind of odd given
that the parts before only covered a
period of few years
something we also consider possible is a
prequel that takes place before the
first part
this third scenario is not unlikely
especially because
neither the universe know the characters
would have to be changed
they could for example focus on life
before hiccup's birth or tell the story
of the village of burke thus
show the audience a bit more of the
truly
lovingly designed world as a fourth and
final option
we also envision one or more spin-offs
in any case the film universe has enough
interesting side characters
stories about the former lives of
hiccup's parents astrid or
of course toothless come to mind in the
case of the latter for example they
could tell us how the dragon got to
burke in the first place and how he
became the dragon he is
we definitely think this is the most
likely option partly due to the fact
that this scenario offers a
lot more creative possibilities the
fourth scenario is also supported by the
fact that director de bla already wrote
of the rest in 2014
things would be different with spin-offs
of course since the original by author
cressida cowell also consists of 12
books hence the franchise is far from
dead but it's highly unlikely that fans
can expect a seamless follow-up in the
form of a possible part 4.
now naturally we are interested in your
opinion how likely do you think the
sequel to the how to train your dragon
series is
and which scenario would you prefer feel
free to leave your thoughts in the
comments section below and
if you like the latest original be sure
to subscribe and leave us a like
see you next time
[Music]
bye